et comment cette fumée pour faire comme
les autres et ensuite habitudes
maintenant par plaisir 1976 pas de stylo
à la main mais plutôt une cigarette dès
le collège question de mode à cette
époque 30 % des moins de 17 ans fumer
régulièrement dans le détail toujours en
1976 7 % des 10 12 ans étaient fumeurs
30% chez les 13-15 ans et 54 % chez les
16-17 ans à cette époque fumer des
clopes c'est être dans le coup c'est
vrai et pour bon nombre de parents
ce n'était pas un problème bien au
contraire par dix mois côté santé ils
sont déjà conscients des risques liés au
tabagisme
entre 1977 et 1997 les 12 18 ans se
détache peu à peu du tabac près de la
moitié des garçons fumée en 1977
ils n'étaient plus que 23,8 % en 1997
quant aux filles les chiffres passent de
43% à 26,9 pour cent il a fallu attendre
2004 pour que la vente de cigarettes
soit interdit aux moins de 16 ans puis
2010 pour les mineurs néanmoins la règle
n'est pas respectée par tous les
buralistes
illustration en 2014 en caméra cachée
[Musique]
depuis 2000 la consommation de tabac
chez des français de 17 ans est étudiée
et c'est très net la clope n'est plus
autant à la mode
ils étaient 40 et 1,1 pour cent à fumer
quotidiennement et plus que 25,1 pour
cent en 2010 est en revanche à partir de
2018 un autre mode de consommation
séduit des adolescents
la cigarette électronique début je
voulais essayer et en fait j'ai accroché
alors
il ya plein de variétés debout tout ça
qui diffère en majorité les adultes
utilisent la vap autant substitue à la
cigarette classique chez les adolescents
c'est différent elle peut être le
premier contact avec la nicotine en 2019
52,1 % des lycéens avaient déjà
expérimenté la cigarette électronique
[Musique]